I'm tired of hearing about how these
rids it has a private jet I won't have a
private jet someday I don't anybody to
tell me there's anything wrong with
having a private jet
punks are hearing about his bankruptcies
honestly that's just a corporate tool
that everybody uses and if it's a flaw
in the system then so be it every
corporation uses it and I think that if
you get somebody in there who
understands the things that crony
capitalism is created you might be able
to actually get rid of those things
we're not electing the head pastor of
the United States we're electing the
commander-in-chief side here about his
like racism it's his little hearts
that's true he's little hearts on it
however no cares about our country he's
you know been fortunate enough to be a
you know it's just been successful and
he's just giving background
he's like Jordan Washington you know he
really wants to help our country I'm
tired of hearing about how Donald
Trump's like a celebrity he's obviously
an intelligent businessman he's made a
lot of money in his life he knows what
is going to be right for this country he
knows what he needs to do to make
America great again
bigger picture he's an intelligent
businessman and you don't get as far as
he's gotten by being stupid yeah you're
mr. Donald Trump I'd like to take a
minute to introduce you to my father I
would love Monza as you so eloquently
put it he is one of the many that Mexico
sensed